foreign
[Music]
it's a step into the future by America's
largest automaker on Thursday General
Motors unveiled one of its most
important new electric vehicles a small
mass-market SUV called The Equinox EV
SUVs make up more than half of new car
sales in the U.S but finding one that's
electric can be difficult with demand
rising and competition heating up GM
took the equinox's design virtual Chris
Van Cleave got exclusive access to the
process at Chevy's Design Center in
Warren Michigan a site where cameras are
rarely allowed inside it may not be the
most glamorous EV to hit the market but
General Motors believes its newly
unveiled 2024 Chevy Equinox EV with a
price tag starting around 30 000 is
critical to its future this is
everything because this is the heart of
the volume
in the market Doug Houlihan is the
executive chief engineer this is the
vehicle you think that drives EV
adoption absolutely it's absolutely a
game changer because of the technology
the features The Styling and how this
SUV is coming to be is also changing the
game with its launch about a year away
GM has yet to build a fully functioning
prototype the bulk of the design work is
happening virtually which is cheaper and
faster shaving about two years off its
development this is one of the more
unusual interviews I've done because
we are inside the super secret GM Design
Center where cameras are rarely allowed
this doesn't look like much of a car but
once designers and Engineers Don this
virtual reality gear they get a look and
feel for how the new Equinox is shaping
up inside and out it's surprisingly
realistic you like see the back seat
yeah
yeah in the rearview mirror that's not
there
laughs
I'll let you take that in for a moment
Jennifer kraska is Chevy's interior
design director it's let us be a lot
more agile we can do multiple iterations
very quickly with this with this
technology so you can really get a sense
of what it would be like to be in this
specific environment The Equinox EV will
be longer and wider than the gas powered
version to make room for Batteries
offering range of 250 to 300 miles on a
full charge
key to maximizing that range is
aerodynamics Engineers have been pouring
over computer models looking for spots
to improve performance before a
full-scale clay model is tested in GM's
Wind Tunnel right now I'm getting hit
with about 30 miles an hour worth of
wind they can crank this up to 70 miles
an hour that's almost hurricane poor
strength it's also freeway speeds and
lets them look at a prototype and see
where they can make small improvements
so what can you do in here that you
can't do with a virtual reality model on
a computer getting into the millimeter
details small changes especially when
we're working with a full-size vehicle
can make a very big difference
small tweaks in here picked up 10 to 15
miles in range and hitting the right
range is key to delivering Equinox EV
for around thirty thousand Tim Stevens
covers the Auto industry something that
can get you over 250 miles for that
amount of money that I think it
definitely has the potential for selling
like hotcakes EV ownership is surging in
the U.S fueled by a growing roster of
options
and high gas prices California plans to
ban the sale of new gas powered vehicles
by 2035. by then analysts predict EVS
will be 40 to 45 percent of all new
vehicle sales but try buying an EV today
and you're likely to land on a months or
even years-long waiting list
are there going to be enough of them
that your average person can go to a
dealer and buy one we're going to offer
this in in steps and we do expect to
ramp up quickly it's a challenge that
the industry's struggling with right now
and we are pushing hard to make that
happen a push that's increasingly
happening virtually for CBS Saturday
morning I'm Chris Van Cleave in Warren
Michigan
I like it in the white yeah it looks
nice I'm just wondering if they still
don't if they're supposed to release it
a year and they still don't have an
actual working prototype yet well then
do you have to wait another year to get
it who and does that increase the price
I think that's what they're trying to
hold off for because that by the way go
shop for an SUV and find one for 30.
yeah you can't exactly yeah